this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman all right
sexy cab work your magic Logan wants to
get a little gamma-ray action from Elora
I don't [ __ ] to help although I would
at home that'd be amazing
yeah that music just kicked in total is
like let me give you a back rub oh sure
now you don't have it let's try to let
me give you a back rub all right I can't
work with that all right turn it off and
we'll do it again when I snap on a snap
on snap off here was a Napper Laura
[Music]
you've already [ __ ] him I just give up
the ass that's what he's asking for and
then make him give up the ass and you
fist him to the wrist girl Crisco
[Music]
why does that bum you out fisting snout
your no go to there because it's only
fair you're asking like a [ __ ] lady
like I won't put my dick in there you
should be able to take a fist in your
it's very different [ __ ] thinking
how much better anal would be if you
were like you know how are in this with
her [ __ ] fist that's a loss in my
column if I had sex with a woman without
a fist in my ass I'm the winner if I had
to take a fist of my ass at best it's a
tie what about a strap what about what
about strap on I'm all for that you've
said that a little too honestly dude
[ __ ] your joke I was sitting right here
holy [ __ ] right monster come out you're
like I'm all for that
in all honesty I've had an interesting
life to tell I'm not ashamed of this I
have a dated a few adult entertainers in
my life and some of them had interesting
peccadilloes turn these lights down I'm
not giving you no I'm not giving you
fodder no stop it
never mind what's worse than you do
what's the worst thing you had let be
done to you I would have to say allowing
a toy to be used on me really yeah what
kind of toy like [ __ ] an admiral
ackbar
or a [ __ ] a slinky an etch-a-sketch
was in my ass all right what do you
think what kind of [ __ ] toy Oh a sex
toy yeah a cylindrical sex toy was used
in my ass so dick shaped I guess one
could point out it's a that resembles a
penis all right you're not helping
how was it did it help did it intensify
it give us some [ __ ] advice you're
like a [ __ ] exploring a sexual
Magellan man yeah tell those of us who
are like no way tell us how good it was
i'm Amerigo Vespucci that's who it was
intense and it did alter the experience
significantly yes no because look it's
biology there's the prostate gland yeah
that when that gets stimulated it
keeping this very clinical because we're
all adults it can intensify your your
ejaculation some you shoot further you
go for distance is that what this is
about going for speed all alone all
alone at the time of meet is that you're
[ __ ] jerk-offs or something that cake
song you're that cakes are not at all
I'm going for distance I'm going for
speed that's all about calm no auto
racing it's applicable like holy [ __ ]
everyone knows this song about come but
me it's applicable you said he's going
for distance just make me think of that
song increases volume and force yes this
[ __ ] it's gone awkward go back to the
show all I can see is you being like
that was not my face or my sound I'll
have you know and then when you come
you're like oh so you're saying you've
never had anyone enter that zone no I've
had a hair brush up my eyes told you not
the business and the brush the the
handle
least I had something meant for my ass
you're picking up random household
objects and sticking them in your ass
that's one way to look at it the other
way is I'm outside the [ __ ] box oh
yeah okay you did what was expected you
took a sex toy me I'm like give me a
brush all right right outlaw
[Music]
you
[Music]